ja wir schalten man nach Brüssel zu
Michael Grütz das war eine hektische
Nacht auch noch irgendwie ein hektischer
morgen aber dann doch relativ schnell
etwas klarer das Bild das ist kein
Angriff Russlands auf die NATO gewesen
ist gibt es da jetzt eine gewisse
Erleichterung im NATO-Hauptquartier und
insgesamt auch in Brüssel
also schon sagen dass die Aufregung
natürlich gestern groß war und dass das
die große Sorge ist die man die ganze
Zeit schon hatte dass dieser Krieg in
der Ukraine in irgendeiner Form auch
immer auf das Territorium der NATO
überschwappen könnte und diese
Befürchtung stand dann natürlich sofort
im Raum das ist klar ich weiß nicht ganz
genau wann sich die ersten Überlegungen
offenbart haben dass es sich hier genau
um das handelt könnte was wir gerade im
Einspieler gesehen haben aber im Laufe
des Abends ist dann offensichtlich die
erste Erkenntnis gereift das ist in
diese Richtung gehen könnte spätestens
als das Weiße Haus mitgeteilt hat dass
man keine Bestätigung hat dass es eine
russische Rakete sein könnte ist dann
doch etwas mehr Ruhe eingekehrt und
spätestens als die ersten Überlegungen
von Präsident beiden kamen dass es
unwahrscheinlich ist ist die Sache etwas
ruhiger geworden heute morgen haben sich
dann die Dinge verdichtet bis dann eben
auch heute Mittag denn
Nato-Generalsekretär hier in Stoltenberg
so deutlich gesagt hat wie wir es gerade
aus Polen aus dem Einspieler gehört
haben es war dann doch gestern Abend
auch über die Nacht relativ schnell auch
von Artikel 4 und auch Artikel 5 der
NATO zu ziehen die Rede da ist man
vielleicht auch ganz erleichtert dass
man relativ schnell dann auch eine
Klarheit hatte dass man da nicht noch
weiter darüber nachdenken muss oder
ja wobei diese Artikel 5 Diskussion ist
von Leuten aufgebracht worden die
vielleicht etwas zu aufgeregt mit dieser
Frage umgegangen sind man muss bei
Artikel 5 als meiner Sicht
außerordentlich vorsichtig sein denn
diese beistandsklausel wenn man die denn
zöge erstens gibt es keinen Automatismus
dafür das muss hier besprochen werden
das müssen alle miteinander so
beschließen auf dem Vorschlag eines
einzelnen und zweitens hätte er
erhebliche Konsequenzen das ist eine
eine hoch seriöse Angelegenheit mit der
man außerordentlich vorsichtig umgehen
muss und da waren gestern Abend doch
einige unterwegs die viel zu schnell mit
seiner Frage aufkam hier in der NATO war
das den ganzen Abend über kein Thema
erst später kam auf das Polen
möglicherweise die Frage von Artikel 4
das heißt dass man Konsultationen
einberuft weil sich ein Territorium
bedroht fühlt
aufruft aber auch das war dann heute
morgen durch als man dann die Erkenntnis
immer klarer hatte
dass es sich dann doch
höchstwahrscheinlich weil die finalen
abschlussuntersuchungen sind noch nicht
durch aber das ist sich
höchstwahrscheinlich um ukrainische
Raketen handelt wurde dann doch in der
Tat ihr Erleichterung größer aber
nochmal vorsicht mit solchen
Ankündigungen die gestern dann teilweise
kursierten ja
nichtsdestotrotz müssen wir natürlich in
Bilder haben starke Raketenangriffe
Russlands auf die Ukraine dieser Krieg
geht weiter und die NATO wurde quasi
jetzt auch noch mal zwischendurch auch
wachgerüttelt das heißt Unterstützung
für die Ukraine das ist trotzdem weiter
das Thema auch heute gewesen oder
absolut es gab auch es gibt ja die
sogenannte
nato-kontaktgruppe weil die NATO ja den
Eindruck vermeiden will dass die NATO
diejenige ist die die Ukraine
unterstützt man will diese klare
Trennlinie haben dass man an diesen
Krieg nicht beteiligt ist also sind es
einzelne NATO Mitglieder die der Ukraine
helfen die haben sich zusammengesetzt in
der sogenannten Kontaktgruppe und da
wird dann darüber geredet wie man die
Flugabwehr in der Ukraine stärken kann
damit das auch koordiniert passiert man
muss auch noch mal hinzusagen dass
Nato-Generalsekretär nochmal sehr
deutlich gemacht hat dass man nicht Teil
dieses Krieges ist und das auch nicht
werden will aber man sieht natürlich
auch die Gefahr die durch solche
Ereignisse wie gestern durchaus gegeben
ist denn das ist an grenzendes Gebiet an
Polen mit der Ukraine und auch jenseits
der polnischen Grenze sind ja Teile
schon heruntergekommen also ganz
unerwartet kam das auch in dem Vernehmen
nach für die Polen nicht und hier wird
dann doch auch festgestellt dass alle
sehr ja zufrieden sind mit der
besonderen Reaktion auch in Polen und
den anderen NATO Mitgliedsländern ich
sage sage Dankeschön an dieser Stelle
nach Brüssel Michael Grütz und wir
schalten mal direkt weiter zu Ina nach
Moskau also die Reaktionen waren relativ
schnell da aus Moskau gab es auch
relativ schnell eine Reaktionen und da
sprach man von Provokationen hat das
natürlich alles zurückgewiesen ist man
da jetzt vielleicht auch so ein bisschen
erleichtert man hört so fast gar nichts
gerade
ja hier ist schon eine Menge Lärm in der
ganzen Geschichte natürlich aber das ist
sehr viel auch ich will jetzt nicht
sagen Genugtuung aber doch
so eine Stimmung wie ihr habt uns gleich
den schwarzen Peter zugeschoben es gibt
diese Russe Phobie die hier immer
beschworen wird nicht dass man da
angeblich hysterisch reagiere im Westen
und da ist man hier doch jetzt so ein
bisschen in so einer Art Position der
Genugtuung dass man sagt seht ihr es
waren doch die Ukraine offenbar selbst
ihr könnt es ja gar nicht beweisen dass
wir es waren und wir waren es ja auch
gar nicht das ist schon hier so ein
Thema man hat interessanterweise hier so
ein kleines Lob für die Amerikaner nicht
also anders als die wie es hier heißt
hysterischen Polen und die
erstaunlicherweise sagt man das hier
sogar russophoben Ukraine und niemand
wundert sich darüber dass da vielleicht
wirklich gerade keine große Freundschaft
zur Ukraine zu Russland besteht in der
Ukraine also neben diesen beiden Ländern
habe doch die USA recht besonnen
reagiert Präsident beiden recht besonnen
reagiert das verkündet man hier fast
stolz also man ist in so einer Situation
in so einer Stimmung hier gerade ja da
ist also der einzige Ausreißer
wahrscheinlich der hermet WTF der so die
NATO und die NATO Verbündeten
bezichtigte die Welt an den Rand eines
Dritten weltkriegsgerichts gerückt zu
haben oder
genau das gehört dazu hier natürlich man
spricht hier natürlich nach wie vor auch
von Provokationen bewusster
eskalationsversuche der Polen die die
NATO da mit reinziehen hätten wollen das
ist natürlich Thema mit Video hat jetzt
noch mal so eine eigene Rolle der fällt
ja auf durch diese besonders harten
Äußerungen ob das jetzt wirklich einfach
das ist was er da jetzt gerade immer mal
in die Welt raus tweeten will oder ob er
da nicht auch eine bestimmte Rolle sogar
erfüllt das ist nicht so ganz klar aber
sicherlich ist es so dass man ihnen hier
nicht so richtig ernst nimmt in dem was
er da sagt aber natürlich er wird gehört
der wird auch vor allem im Westen gehört
aber er hat auch keine wirkliche Macht
hier im Moment also nehmen wir mal diese
Vorfälle von gestern Abend da ist eine
Rakete die geht außerhalb des Gebiets in
dass man es schießen möchte und Russland
hat ja beispielsweise gestern mit über
90 fast 100 Raketen und
Marschflugkörpern die Ukraine
angegriffen das kann jederzeit passieren
hatten wir auch im Gespräch gerade mit
Michael Grütz das Thema diese dieses RIS
dafür dass der irläufer unterwegs sind
es wäre ja nichts zum ersten Mal bei
Russland und bei dieser Technik
kalkuliert man das in Moskau tatsächlich
mit ein und weiß eben auch wenn man dann
das nato-bündnisgebiet trifft das ist
das Schwierigkeiten geben könnte
man weiß sicherlich dass man also dass
man
Ärger bekommen würde mit der NATO wenn
da mehr solcher Vorfälle passieren würde
ob man das einkalkuliert oder nicht
schwer zu sagen ich meine ich muss hier
auch immer sehr vorsichtig sein dass ich
die russische Armee nicht diskreditiere
aber die Treffgenauigkeit der Raketen da
kann man zumindest drüber diskutieren
hier hieß es übrigens heute das war sehr
interessant der
Militärsprecher sagte heute in seinem
offiziellen Briefing man habe gestern ja
hochgenauigkeitsraketen abgefeuert auf
das gesamte Territorium der Ukraine das
wurde also stolz verkündet aber man habe
natürlich nicht entlang der ukrainischen
polnischen Grenze Ziele
befeuert oder getroffen 35 Kilometer
davon entfernt von der Grenze habe man
sich daran gehalten und und das war sehr
interessant man habe auch Kiew nicht
beschossen und das was da in Kiew heute
so wie er das dann ausdrückt
demonstriert wurde als Ziel von und als
zer Erfahrungen in Wohngebieten das habe
sich Kiew ganz alleine
beigefügt nämlich dass sein alles
Schäden von ukrainischen
Luftabwehrraketen man nutzt also quasi
die Chance dass es da mittlerweile ja
fast eine
einstimmige Meinung darüber gibt dass es
offenbar eine ukrainische
Luftabwehrrakete war in Polen und
bezieht das auch glaube ich mit auf Kiew
ein und sagt wir haben da nicht
geschossen das waren die Ukrainer selbst
das ist noch mal ganz interessant heute
also halten wir fest aufatmen nicht nur
in Moskau sondern auch rundherum das
nichts wirklich Schlimmes passiert ist
um diese Bündnisfall nicht eintreten
musste dadurch Dankeschön nach Moskau